nominated for Oscars for his
performances in born on the 4th of July
Jerry Maguire and Magnolia ladies and
gentlemen Tom Cruise
tonight we're going to take a moment to
acknowledge a humanitarian with the Jean
Hersholt award she is an uncommon
individual a singular woman her name is
Cheri Lansing and I have had
I've had the good fortune of knowing her
my entire career and I can tell you that
she is the very personification of what
this significant award represents born
and raised in Chicago sherry came to
Hollywood to pursue a career in acting
but she found her true calling behind
the scenes she began as a script reader
and story editor rising in the ranks to
become a production executive at
Columbia Pictures where she oversaw a
series of highly acclaimed films in 1980
sherry made history by becoming the
first female president of a major studio
at 20th Century Fox
she put her unique stamp on an ambitious
slate of projects believing that films
can not only entertain but also make you
think transitioning from executive to
independent producer sherry brought to
the screen such controversial
thought-provoking films as the accused
and fatal attraction in 1992 sherry was
named chairman of Paramount Pictures
there she enjoyed an unprecedented
12-year run that resulted in a spectrum
of critical and box office successes
including the oscar-winning best
pictures Forrest Gump Braveheart and
Titanic
but for all of her achievements sherry
always made time to give back to the
community when her mother died of cancer
Cherie :
stop cancer one of the many
organizations she has supported to fund
cancer research passionate about
education
sherry sits on the board of Teach for
America and established a scholarship
fund through the Big Sisters of Los
Angeles
she was also appointed a region to the
University of California her ongoing
work with the American Red Cross and the
Carter Center is helping to eradicate
childhood diseases around the world in
the area of stem cell research
sherry joined the California state board
that oversees a distribution of three
billion dollars in funding and she is
launching a new program called prime
time to place outstanding retirees and
volunteer positions after a legendary 30
year career
sherry recently left show business to
devote herself full-time to her
nonprofit foundation she leaves behind a
legacy of classic films but promises to
make an even greater impact through her
humanitarian work in the years ahead
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Sherry Lansing
I am deeply honored and very grateful to
receive this award but I also must admit
that it feels a little strange to be
singled out so many of you have causes
that you are equally passionate about
that is really what is so wonderful
about the movie industry not only do we
get to make films that matter but we
also work in a culture where we are
encouraged to speak out we may not
always agree but we do always care
through my work I have met scientists
who struggle every day to find cures for
diseases they do so quietly without
glamor or attention but always with
passion and conviction I have met
schoolteachers who are battling against
insurmountable odds and yet they never
stop trying to reach our children to me
they are the real heroes and tonight I
share this honor with all of them and a
personal note I want to thank my husband
Billy and our two boys Cedric and Jack
whose unconditional love gives me the
courage to fight every day for what I
believe in and a special thank you to
the members of the Academy for this
extraordinary honor I promise to spend
the rest of my life trying to live up to
it thank you so much thank you